-Wow. Thank you.
That's -- That's very --
You -- Wow.
You didn't need to stand up.
That's nice. Okay, um --
Well, I was walking down
the street the other day -
Has anyone here turned 33?
Okay, so, if you're
a 33-year-old white woman,
this joke is gonna crush.
Okay. So, I was
walking down the street.
I was doing some window
shopping, and I was, like,
looking at this window.
I was like, "That's cute.
That's cute. That's cute."
I look up. "Ann Taylor."
"Oh, no!"
I got Ann Taylor'ed,
and, you know --
It gives me a chill.
Every time I even hear
the words "Ann Taylor,"
I just hear my mom go,
"They got a petite section."
I don't even know
if it's a store.
I just know it's a portal
to menopause, you know?
But I'm trying -- I'm trying
to stay young, you know?
I'm trying to stay young.
I'm going to parties.
Mm-hmm. I'm going to parties
Like, I went to a party th
other night, and I just kind o
was talking to the same
three people the whole night
I thought, "This is great.
We don't need anybody else."
And then this woman comes up
to us, and she goes,
"How would you rate this party?"
And, you know, I think,
"I don't need to wait
for the others to answer.
I can say. Nine."
And then everyone else
in the circle said, "Six."
And that's just a lesson
for you as an adult.
If you're at a party
and you're having a nine,
everyone else is having a six.
That's just the Ann Taylor brand
for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got -- Thanks.
Yeah, give it up for Ann Taylor.
Dress -- Yeah.
I got a dog recently.
And when you get --
A lot of people,
when they get a dog, they say,
"Oh, my dog's
so good, so smart."
And it turns out
I got a dumb and bad one.
He's really awful.
He bit my cousin.
He ripped my dad's pants off
Uh, he's terrible.
So we took him to this trainer
and the trainer was like,
"Oh, you're doing it all wrong
You got to be walking him
for three hours a day,
feeding him hard-boiled eggs."
Essentially we're turning
this dog into John Cena.
And, I mean,
it seems insane to me
to make a bad dog stronger
but that's --
That's what we're doing.
But I -- So I got --
It was hard to even get the do
because I got the dog
with my boyfriend.
He was really picky
about the dog.
He didn't want the dog
to be too big, too small.
He wanted it to be brown.
He wanted ears to go like that
And he didn't want to be abl
to feel the bones.
[ Laughter ]
You guys know
that part of the dog
that gives it the shape
of the dog?
[ Laughter ]
My mom's friend, Mary, was like,
"Honey, he wants
a chicken finger."
[ Laughter ]
True. Mary's right.
I mean, we obviously --
You know, we live together
Has anyone moved in with
someone they wanted to love?
[ Laughter ]
It's -- Things change
when you live with somebody.
You know, like,
the other day, he goes --
He goes, "Babe, come in here
I'm a genius."
So I stopped what I'm doin
because, you know,
obviously my baby's a genius
I got to go check, you know.
And so I go over to him,
and I look
and he's eating cereal.
And instead of milk,
it's peanut butter.
[ Laughter ]
That -- That's a disappointment.
You know, but he's so --
he's so proud.
And I want this to work,
so I say to him, I say,
"Well, sweetie, you -- you
just made the thickest snack
[ Laughter ]
You just made a snack
fit for a horse."
And then I went
into the bathroom
and screamed for three minutes
But I've been -- You know, I'v
working on the relationship.
Working on friendships.
2020, you know.
You know, just trying to connect
with people more.
It's hard --
It's hard to connect for me.
Like, I don't know
if you guys have noticed this,
but I haven't looked
at any one of you in the eyes.
And if I make it
to the end of the set,
I do get an ice-cream cone
[ Laughter ]
But I'm trying. You know,
I am really trying, you know
And, like,
I've been doing this outreac
with the neighborhood kids
that's been really great.
It's this activity I made up
It's called liquid telephone
And basically I just get 10 kids
to line up in a row,
and the first kid
gets a mouthful of juice,
and then they just pass it
mouth to mouth...
[ Audience groans ]
And then the kid at the en
has to guess the flavor.
[ Laughter ]
I guess that's why
I'm a six at parties.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-You're a 10! You're a 10!
Jo Firestone!
Listen to her on the "National
Lampoon Radio Hour: The Podcast"
available on Spotify.